Lori Loughlin is at an all-time low as
she continues to fight charges in
connection with the College Admission
scandal a source tells ET I think the
likelihood that Laurier spends prison
time is very very high because of the
seriousness of the crime and the amount
of money that we're dealing with here he
confirmed on Wednesday that Lori and her
husband Massimo Jian Ellie's legal team
officially entered not guilty pleas to
new charges of conspiracy to commit
federal program bribery now a source
tells ET quote she is breaking down she
truly feels at her very worst people are
coming out in support of her lately but
she is afraid to open up she's concerned
if she talks to the wrong people that
her opinions will get out and somehow
affect the case according to the source
her daughter's 20 year-old Olivia Jade
and 21 year-old Isabella are getting
more worried about her lori and massimo
are accused of paying five hundred
thousand dollars in bribes to get their
daughters admitted to USC as recruits
for the crew team even though neither of
them had ever participated in the sport
i just want them to have that experience
and get that education and have a degree
to fall back on in april the couple
submitted not guilty pleas and now
Olivia and Bella are no longer enrolled
at USC I want them to be happy so I want
to be supportive of everything they want
to do but I do want them to have
somewhat of a normal you know finish out
of high school college experience maybe
because I didn't have that I would
really want that for them ET source says
they are trying to help her process but
it's been really hard the girls feel
guilty because they realize she was only
trying to help their future they know
their mother is a good person and don't
want her to suffer in any way the source
added that her friends are supporting
her and keep reminding her if she does
time behind bars she will get through
this
ét recently spoke to Teresa Giudice who
served time behind bars for mail wire
and bankruptcy fraud I feel like where
women are strong we have babies we do it
all I'm sure whatever outcome it is I'm
sure she'll be
and she offered her advice to Lori just
be open with them and whatever the
outcome is it is we have to deal with it
and move forward
[Music]